make some noise for [ __ ] jokes what
[Music]
you lose here watching with friends
whizzing by how many do you think
bedbugs were at that mention of the bed
oh my god they've got a better natural
dark minutes the bedbugs in the name
[Music]
happy so going upwards I've never done
that before
I know that you make very your life like
a tree you do it like a play pretty
dangerous
a black man's a baby as a gay black
children a hero I think I'm about to and
not just someone like Michael Jordan or
Serena Williams or Joe Lewis Jackie
Robinson movies or Douglas Carter jr.
[Music]
Rosa Parks
Maya Angelou now the big person that
dress look at can
when I come out of the Asian movie huh
[Music]
my job
let's go your friendship we start moving
in crazier changes but I hated all my
Asian friends act like this was our big
coming-out party but if we haven't been
a civilization for 2,000 years we've
been to the compass
okay I mean that four minutes before
looking at my nose
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like me I can be high you know I heard
about all these people and so often when
you're I can't deny you have to be the
high for public people and then your
friends make fun of you for being on it
yeah so we know the intended results and
she's my goal thank you for noticing oh
my god I love being I don't
I am in a van so I can pursue comedy of
all time
[Music]
I'm doing that so I pursue comedy
full-time so if you don't think I'm very
funny I'm sorry I'm pregnant
it's a lot of pressure on me now people
like yeah that was funny but not live
your car money could have written that
joke in the park buddy
Fisher today because within the shelter
they disobey and go home with me what
usually ends up happening is we go for a
drive I was wanting to work up the
courage to tell her we were 45 minutes
ago
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]